hello everyone and welcome to the
Armageddon game uh from the final round
of the Champions Chester finals let me
just switch the little uh the letter on
the little robot uh so it doesn't say
rapid uh sorry about that uh and it's a
really really wild game uh because in
order to get the black pieces is it's
always better to be black in Armageddon
H you have to bid your time because
players start with 15 minutes and you
can bid as much time as you want you can
bid a minute you can bid 2 minutes 5
minutes uh but then if you win the bid
uh you will have uh that um much less
time on the clock when you start the
game so you know it's it's nice to bid a
lot but of course you will have less
time to play and ala won the bit here
and that's why he got the black pieces
you know which is it looks to be weird
because you know when you start learning
chess you know you are taught that it's
always better to be white uh not so much
in Armageddon because now it's okay for
ala to draw and he wins the match the
first two games that they played were
absolutely Wild to watch I will not
analyze them as they're uh it's more of
a joy to watch them actually play it
than to analyze it since it's really
fast and there are so many mistakes the
first game is a real blunder Fest so if
you have a chance and you have time do
check it out so Alesa won the first one
second game Magnus retaliated he really
went all out with the black pieces and
um played a very nice game but now it's
time to see what happened in the
Armageddon so let's check it out Magnus
has the white pieces and he opened with
Pawn to D4 and ala replied with D5 I
allowed the clocks for this video and
you can see he starts with 9 minutes I
think he bid like 8 minutes and 59 58
seconds so a considerably lower time he
starts with six minutes less uh so let's
see if this is enough for Magnus to win
the game we have Pon to C4 and now Pawn
to C6 the slav defense and it it um
quite a lot rides on this game for ala
if he loses the match to Magnus now H
he's out of the tournament we have Pawn
to E3 we have Knight to F6 and now
Knight to C three with have Bishop to F5
so a pretty standard SLO defense setup
and now Pawn to F3 an extremely rare
move and it is what Magnus has to do in
order to get um a nice game and now Ala
plays Pawn to H6 and it is now as of
move five already that we have a
completely new
game uh yeah sorry about that uh and now
Magnus rushes forward with Pawn to G4 he
attacks the bishop here Bishop to H7 and
now Bishop to D3 offering a trade of
Bishops which all it is happily goes for
captures captures and now Pawn to E6 uh
Knight GT E2 continuing development the
Knight might end up somewhere like F4
maybe D3 maybe E5 in the future uh
Knight B to D7 and now C captures on D5
we have C captures on D5 and the bishop
to D2 ala goes Pawn to A6 grabs hold of
the B5 Square pref prepares further
expansion with Pawn to B5 and H4 by
Magnus he starts attacking on the king
Side Pawn to B5 and now King to F2 not
even castling the king will be safe here
Magnus wants to attack the black king
still in the center of the board we have
Bishop to D6 and now Pawn to G5 uh
Knight to H5 of course you cannot
capture here as if you capture then just
H captures and G5 and you have uh big
problems here for example you trade
Rooks uh Rook captures on H1 and now you
have to deal with the threat of Pawn
captures Knight and also the threat of
Rook to h8 check and if you play Knight
to G8 something like uh Rook to h8 and
King to f8 uh the defending then Queen
to H7 and you resign here there's no
defending disposition so instead after
G5 Knight to H5 by Ala and now Pawn to
E4 so first playing on the king side and
now striking in the center Magnus trying
to control the entire board here D
captures Knight captures attacking the
bishop Bishop back to E7 and now even
Pawn to A4 so really using the entire
board uh the idea is to put pressure on
B5 he wants to capture win a pawn and
can alza stop this somehow uh well our
good friends the engines they taught us
that whenever someone does something
like this you should you should play the
anti positional move and you should be
okay but humans just don't do that so Al
Hasa play Knight to E5 uh it's a nice
tactic as the Knight cannot be captured
the queen on D3 is undefended so Queen
to B3 uh still putting pressure on the
pawn uh and now we have Knight to C4 uh
so very tricky going after the bishop on
D2 so Bishop to B4 and now alza has to
decide the best would be to play Bishop
captures and B4 but it's still or maybe
even Rook to B8 but to give you an
example of what happens captures
captures and queen E7 okay you can trade
Queens uh Queen to C5 and this is how
you force a queen trade because black
cannot Castle the queen will be hanging
here and if you trade then Magnus will
get a pass C Pawn so that's the idea but
ala went Pawn to F5 he wants to go after
the white king as well uh Bishop
captures on E7 Queen captures and now
Knight to C5 and how do you defend the
the B5 Pawn there's really not a good
way to do it now you can't even capture
here as the Knight on C4 would hang you
cannot even defend it if Rook to B8 you
play Knight captures on A6 if you play
uh what can you play if you bring the
Knight here to defend it then you lose
the E6 Pawn the Knight is blocking the
queen from attacking the pawn here so
ala says all right I can't defend it
let's just leave it there and uh you
know try to beat me with an extra pawn
and Magnus says all right it's not just
an extra Pawn it's an extra B Pawn so a
captures a captures Rook captures on A8
Rook captures and queen captures on B5
with an attack on the Knight Knight to
D6 attacks magnus's Queen here and queen
to B3 again introduces the attack to the
E6 pawn and Rook to E8 ala defends it
and now Magnus has the pass B Pawn but
also he has a very unpleasant pressure
on the G file so Rook to G1 threatens G
captures on H6 so ala quickly gets away
from the G file Knight to D3 now REM
maneuvering the Knight F4 and PA Pawn to
G6 uh not allowing the advancement of
the white Pawn to G6 uh we have Knight E
to4 Queen to B6 is also very nice here
but um Magnus is also playing a little
bit on ala time he's down to 3 minutes
and Magnus has over 10 minutes on the
clock so he doesn't want to overuse his
time Knight E to F4 Knight captures on
F4 Knight captures and H captures on G5
H captures and now Knight to F7 and it
seems like halza figured out how to how
to survive this position Magnus played
Queen to E3 again putting pressure on
this Pawn with some ideas of even
advancing the pawn to D5 and now alz
just went for Knight captures um on G5
probably Rook to B8 was just saf as
going after the B Pawn and then after
Rook to B1 uh you you take it from there
but he went for Knight captures on G5
and now Magnus plays Queen to E5 again
D5 here is very nice because you can
never capture if you capture then uh
Queen just get traded off the board uh
and um uh the the Knight on G5 is
undefended so instead after Knight
captures on G5 Magnus went for the queen
to E5 and now Knight to F7 attacking the
queen and now we have a rook to H1 check
King to G8 and queen to B5 now now just
keeping the queen on E7 as The Rook
would hang also defending the pawn here
preparing to advance it it's a nice
position from magnes the G6 Pawn still
hanging so King to G7 defending and now
Queen to C6 just applying more pressure
here uh G5 chasing away the Knight and
now Knight to D3 also Rook to G1 does
look very nice but Magnus went for
Knight to D3 Rook to d8 and now Queen
back to C3 trying to throw in some
discoveries here so Queen to F6 and now
Knight to C5 again uh going for for some
checking action here once the pawn is
Advanced so King to G6 unpinning from
this long diagonal uh and now Rook to D1
Magnus puts the Rook behind the D Pawn
uh and now Pawn to E5 here the the
position is still okay for alza he has
to play Rook to D6 or or something like
G4 and okay it it continues but he
played Pawn to E5 and this is very very
dangerous now but he is very long time
he has less than a minute 45 seconds on
the clock so D captures on E5 Queen to
h8 and now as he defends The Rook we
have Rook captures Queen to H2 with
check uh King to E3 and now he has to
recapture Knight captures on d8 we have
King to D4 by Magnus and now Pawn to G4
and uh how can Magnus win this well H he
can't really if alza plays Everything
correctly F captures and G4 and now you
have to play F captures on G4
recapturing but Al ala threw in this
queen to F2 check and this is just
enough to get Magnus into the the
winning position King to D5 was played
and only now F captures on G4 now we
have Pawn to E6 advancing the pawn uh
Queen to F5 with check this is the final
mistake for ala we have King to D six
and now Queen to F3 offering a queen
trade uh but it does seem little good
Queen captures on F3 was played uh G
captures and now Knight to D3 going
after the Pawn King F6 and now we have
Pawn to E7 Knight to F7 check King to D7
and here alza played Pawn to F2 but he
was also in this position on move 51
that ala fuja lost on time and that's
pretty much it which is which is which
is a a huge
shame uh because this is one one
beautiful position it's not easily
winning I mean you you really have to
work hard to win this position H but it
has a very very cool theme that I'm sure
you guys will enjoy so even though the
game is already over uh feel free to
pause the video and try to find the only
winning idea for Magnus here while I
give you a couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
this uh well in
inconceivable uh set of moves and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Pawn to E8 with Knight check
that's the move you have to play and
that's the only move that wins now uh
the reason why this is so is because if
you capture the pawn on F2 then look at
this Knight E5 check comes then you move
the king king d8 then Knight to C6 check
comes you lose this pawn and now after
King D7 Knight to captures on E7 and yes
you do have a pass Pawn but the Knight
will simply sacrifice itself for the
pawn it's not uh not not like you can do
anything like Knight G4 check King F7
you can even move the king back and
let's say you start pushing Pawn to B4
Knight D5 attacks the pawn B5 now comes
Knight to C3 again attacks the pawn B6
Knight to A4 again attacks the pawn and
finally B7 Knight lands with C5 check uh
Forks the king and the pawn and once the
king moves of course he will capture the
knight uh the pawn with the Knight and
it will be a draw by insufficient
material so that's why after this Pawn
to F2 move the only winning move is E8
Knight check and then after the king
moves now you capture the pawn you have
to capture it otherwise uh you're going
to only get a draw H but it's still not
easy how do you prevent uh the black
knight from still sacrificing itself for
the pawn well look at this sorcery King
to E5 you will play Knight to D3 with
check King to D4 now you will play
Knight to D6 uh sorry Knight to D6 offer
a knight trade uh King captures on D3
and now you will play Knight captures an
F7 and even though the black king is so
close to the B Pawn the black king
cannot capture it if you go to C2 then
just B4 and the King can never uh C
catch up to the pawn you cannot go C3
and if you try King to C4 trying to play
King to B3 next and King captures on B2
then Knight to E5 check King to B3 and
Knight to D3 defending the pawn so
there's no no way you can do it if King
to C4 attacking the Knight B4 now you
want to give up the Knight so the pawn
marches forward the king will not be
able to catch up to the pawn and if King
B5 now you start um you know shouldering
of the black king king C7 King C4 King
to C6 force him to capture and now the B
Pawn wins the game as it most often does
uh so yeah uh you know really cool game
but I was very sad that it ended here
because the I I very much wanted to see
would Magnus be able to to to pull this
off because he would have to find some
very unique moves and okay he had time
on the clock ala didn't but you know if
he if he you know may made one little
mistake then he would not be able to
pull off a win here uh but yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it very
nicely done by Magnus kicking out ala
out of the out of the event and uh yeah
if you have the time to check out the
first two games uh like I said they're
not really something to analyze but they
are a joy to watch when they are
actually playing them uh so yeah once
again really hope you guys enjoyed it I
would like to thank David gasparian
Nathan I love you Dad Milos kesich
treats foro and David Kimura for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions uh and whatever
else happens in the Chess World uh so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your
day